here with reaction although I'm sure you
don't want to waste much time on it
Senator Lindsey Graham great state of
South Carolina bicubic or worse last
time we played golf
let's go worse but hey judging we've got
my enemies judge me by my enemies I
would I'll take that all day long
alright I want to go back this is an
interesting point Adam the Cowardly
corrupt chef is now we believe a fact
witness is he not
you know he's doing his top-secret you
know Venezuela styler impeachment coup
attempt here and Republicans can't even
read what's going on right would you be
able to call him before your committee I
doubt it the the whole inquiry has been
referred to the Intel committee I'll get
Horowitz here pretty soon but here's
what I'm going to do tomorrow I need
your help quite frankly I've got a
resolution condemning the house process
as being unamerican
basically unfair the president can't
defend himself I'm tired of the
president basically being trashed based
on behind-the-scenes testimony this
one-sided so I'm asking the house to
open up an inquiry consistent with what
we did with Bill Clinton so President
Trump can defend himself as to Adam
Schiff
if he did coach the whistleblower that
would be very interesting if somebody
doesn't find out who the whistleblower
is here pretty soon
that'd be a miscarriage of justice
because the whole thing started with an
anonymous source senator let me go
through the list we'll put it up on the
screen for you but we know that Newt
Gingrich aloud and then this was Kevin
McCarthy's letter aloud the full had the
full house authorized the impeachment
inquiry they allowed the full house in
every critical step in the inquiry to
involve themselves and develop a scope
established rules and procedures Newt
Gingrich allowed for the Democrats eat
the right co-equal right to subpoena the
chair and the ranking member and by the
way all subpoenas was subject to the
vote of the full committee at the
request of the chair and ranking member
and by the way the President's Council
Lindsay he had the right to attend all
hearings all depositions he had the
right to present evidence the right to
cross
Hammond the President's Council had the
right to object to evidence that was
admitted and also the president's
council had a right to recommend a
witness list
now Newt Gingrich did that for Bill
Clinton every one of those things none
of this has happened for Donald Trump
none of it as a matter of fact what's
happened here is that they're
interviewing witnesses behind closed
doors and they give the media part of
the testimony detrimental to the
president like Bill Taylor's opening
statement how did John Radcliffe do when
it came to cross-examining bill Taylor
you'll never know that what they're
trying to do is drive the president's
poll numbers down impeachment poll
numbers up by using basically Star
Chamber tactics this is a political move
by Democrats that will destroy the
presidency in the future it's
illegitimate I'm going to condemn it I
hope every public and will join my
resolution urging the house to do for
President Trump what Newt Gingrich did
for President Clinton give him a chance
you said last night if if they're going
to do a not allowed due process not
allow what Republicans allowed Bill
Clinton and the Democrats to have just
one night long ago 1998 and there were
11 sellers there felonies if I remember
the Independent Counsel statute okay so
if they're not going to allow that to
happen that would be that that whole
inquiry would be lacking in any validity
to me it would also mean it's
unconstitutional but also mean there's
no due process and I don't think that's
anything with any respectable Republican
senator should allow to happen without
dismissing it out of hand well we're
just not jurors in the Senate we can
actually make motions to dismiss dismiss
articles of impeachment here's what I
promise your audience I'll do if they
continue to treat President Trump this
way they continue to try him behind
closed doors to not him the ability to
confront his accuser and they this
results in an impeachment article this
process results in an impeachment
article I will move to dismiss it in the
Senate because I think it's illegitimate
and unconstitutional and I will do it
not only to hell
President Trump who deserves to be
helped but to protect future presidents
from kangaroo court proceedings in the
house all I'm asking Democrats to do is
have a transparent process like we did
with Clinton so the American people can
make a decision as to what happened and
not rely upon a bunch of Democrats to
tell us what happened changing gears
we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting nearly idealize abuse and
waiting and it's kind of Johnson saying
free well we know the facts have been
establish Lindsey that it was an
unverifiable dossier your memo along
with Charles Grassley said the bulk of
information and that application came
from Hillary Clinton's dirty dossier
none of it verified on top of a FISA
warrant says verified that would mean
premeditated fraud on a court if I did
that you're a great lawyer you couldn't
get me out of jail without spending five
years at least I don't know if I could
get you out of jail in this world at all
but the bottom line is Shaun is
horowitz's you may not want me yeah well
I do want you out you need to be right
where you're at talking about what
you're talking about
Horowitz has finished his report the
only thing left to do is to make sure
there's no classified information that
would hurt our national security and
notify people that are mentioned in the
report to get their input so it's done
we'll be getting it pretty soon and can
I end on the Susan Rice thing the bottom
line here is everything she touched
turned to a piece of crap national
security wise it does bother me that the
person who lied about Benghazi is still
relevant
here's her greatest hits the Iran
nuclear deal withdrawal from Iraq the
rise of Isis at the end of the day
Rwanda genocide the Syrian red line the
bottom line is I hope the American
people will remember that as Susan Rice
and Barack Obama who brought you Isis
who gave the Ayatollah 150 billion
dollars and at the end of the day if she
doesn't like me I must be doing
something right amen I agree with that
sir she doesn't like me either
I hope so senator good to see it work
there's a very critical time in our
country's history your work is critical
thank you for being with us